lazy es un procedimiento quirúrgico que
pretende reducir la dependencia de una
persona de los frentes aéreos o de
contacto el término lazy que significa
que era tu miles isla ser in situ y es
un procedimiento que cambia
permanentemente la forma de la córnea
que es la capa transparente que se
encuentra sobre la parte frontal del ojo
lazy que es un procedimiento quirúrgico
ambulatorio que generalmente requiere
alrededor de 15 minutos por ojo antes
del procedimiento se le solicitará que
se recuesta boca arriba y permanezca
quieto se utilizarán gotas tópicas para
anestesiar el ojo y se lavará y limpiará
la zona de alrededor del ojo también se
le puede administrar un sedante para
ayudarlo a relajarse
el médico utilizará un instrumento
denominado especuló de párpados para
mantener abiertos los párpados y luego
colocará un anillo en el ojo que creará
succión en la córnea es posible que
sienta presión y experimente
debilitamiento en la visión en ese
momento de la cirugía una vez que el
anillo esté asegurado en su lugar el
médico colocará un dispositivo especial
denominado micro que era tomo en el
anillo de succión usando la cuchilla de
micro que era tomo el médico creará un
colgajo cortando aproximadamente el 20%
del extremo de la córnea y levantando la
cuidadosamente hacia un lado
después de retirar el anillo de succión
y el micro que era tomo el médico
utilizará pulsos de un láser excimer
controlado por computadora para darle
una nueva forma a la córnea al vaporizar
partes diminutas de su interior
generalmente esta parte del
procedimiento tarda menos de 60 segundos
luego el médico volverá a colocar el
colgajo de la córnea en su posición
original y observará el ojo durante
varios minutos para garantizar la
adherencia debido a que la córnea se
adhiere tan rápido la curación es rápida
y el ojo no requiere puntos
después del procedimiento el médico le
administrará gotas antibióticas y
colocará una protección sobre el ojo
para evitar que lo frote o coloque
presión sobre éste mientras duerme
debido a que no podrá conducir
inmediatamente después del procedimiento
deberá contar con alguien que lo lleve a
su hogar